[Music]
last week I went over games in there so
today I thought I was under instruction
so today I'm going to go over a similar
opening theme but it's going to
hopefully apply to everyone this is
games where black wins against d4 I know
everyone has played back at some point
everyone who's fight against d4 at some
point so I have a kind of interesting
collection of games um maybe one of my
own games but also a lot of games that I
look up to as well so we're going to
start with actually do you guys have any
preferences we could start with my game
we could start with a game from rear
oxen okay
let's start with what the game that I
played trouble months ago this was at
the u.s. amateur team tournaments and it
was kind of a different format than most
tournaments because it was a team event
and the way board sits four player teams
where the board one on one team plays
the board one on the posing team so I
was bored one I was playing kind of a
highest rated player on every other team
and this game I was playing someone
pretty significantly lower rated than me
and I was black and in situations like
this I usually want to play some opening
where I play for women's lack and he
played b4 and for pretty much my whole
life I've been a Queens gambit declined
player we're outside d4 d5 and after c4
e6
does anyone play the same setup as black
only four people here sometimes I'm sure
people online maybe some of you play it
too this is an opening which maybe isn't
known for like great weighing chances
for black especially at the higher
levels but I've used it to some useful
amount of success and I found a lot of
interesting kind of dynamic ideas we're
back and
interesting positions from early on now
in this game I actually didn't start
with d5 I started with mana sticks but
what ended up happening is we transpose
I play e 6
he played 93 l fi d5 and I don't know
there's any clear reason why I did this
I don't entirely remember but I was
probably just giving myself option if I
felt like it I could go for an Indo
Indian but I just stuck with kind of my
own kind of known territory so d5 he
takes this is known as the Queens gambit
declined exchange variation now he plays
Bishop g5 and actually growing up this
was one of the very first openings I
learned and I was taught kind of a
sneaky trap it's not really a great chat
but it's kind of something to know where
I was told to play Knight B d7 here and
the trap is that if white captures a
pawn black to move and punish white for
being too greedy so yeah I take you 5 so
kind of giving into the pin you give
away your clean but then you win the
clean right back digit before and I
believe this was called the elephant's
trap I'm not entirely sure why it's
called elephants trap
it might be because the word Bishop in
Russian is also the same word for
elephant but ok in this case white is
certainly trapped because after the dust
settles life is on a piece for a pawn so
out of my whole chest career I think one
person ever fell into this against me
nowadays I don't like playing Knight bd7
because it blocked suspicion and I would
rather be nice to my pieces so I play
pawn features just solid making sure my
d5 funds well supported now my opponent
plays Queen c2 which is actually kind of
an annoying move because what I wanted
to do next move is play Bishop a5 but
Queen c2 prevents Bishop f5 and may
become it hinders my development process
and I should mention that
for good portion of the scam I was in
opening preparation and I'm still in
opening preparation in this position
meaning I have studied this exact
position before and I knew kind of what
my plan will be so I play a kind of a
rare move here most common move is
probably Bishop e7 I played the more
exotic move Knight a6 and the idea is
kind of twofold one idea is to
potentially play Knight d4 and harass
the Queen the other idea maybe bit more
positional is 1976 just maneuver knight
in the center where I can attack a few
different things so now White has a
choice so I can either allow night
before or prevent night before with a3
and actually a few weeks ago at the club
I played like the Saturday night special
and I got to this position against Farah
Cobian and he was scared of Knight to be
four so he played a3 and then I played
97 and we had a game in this game my
opponent allowed night before we played
III and now interesting things start to
happen and the game kind of potentially
gets very complex but I'll do my best to
explain what's going on so I start with
94 and my opponent plays clean b1 so my
main my main plan with Mac before is to
combine it eventually with Bishop f5 to
create tactics either against the Queen
rule against like the the t2 square so
my opponent keeps the clean on the
diagonal so he's still preventing Bishop
f5 so the natural continuation here is
g6 yeah
preparing Bishop a5 and again I should
note I'm still an opening preparation
this is a position I've studied before
and in this position things could branch
out a few different ways when I want to
spend a little bit of time talking about
how I can branch out of what my opponent
did was not a great move
he played f3 which as you'll see the
internet for well another interesting
move for white is a3
and many years ago I was playing a
tournament in Washington DC I was
actually playing against Poyser not
Sabina for who we all know US Women's
Champion but I was playing against I
believe it was her sister mihaela Pfizer
and before the game I had done all this
preparation in this opening we went into
it she played a three and where I moved
nine right now
I was prepared through move I think was
17 or 18 and we went through all of my
preparation so by the time we reached
like move 17 I had more time than I
started with because we were playing on
increment and I knew the exact computer
evaluation of position and she had like
an hour less than the clock and it was
an equal position but then she lost
consumer so a long time so I'll show you
kind of that that preparation here I
think it's really interesting and I
should also mention that it was like the
only line I prepared before the game I
had maybe had half hour to prepare and
it was just like the pure computer line
so the next several moves for black are
really just all computer moves and
they're hard to understand if you don't
really dig into them deeply so computer
move here for black is to play Bishop a5
actually looks natural the potential
problem and kind of if you're looking at
this for the first time you might
realize that white can play efore and
after e4 then the bishops attacked nice
effect it looks like blacks just losing
a piece but computer comes up with some
nice resources for black what I did in
the game was Bishop taking for night
take e4 Knight takes e4 and we should
probably polish in this position because
it looks like I can go ahead and take
the Knights but this is a poisoned ice
if white takes knife and it's just lost
for white the black has too many or too
much attack after they should take
before White's King just gets way too
exposed
if King e tu aura Kingdom one Queen take
D force coming and the compensations is
overwhelming
so that didn't happen what happened in
again this Poyser was she took on Essex
I took back the Queen
I shouldn't notice the knight still
can't be taken for the same reasons
project before bit should take before
too much conversation for back so she
took on you for and again okay it looks
like White's doing well because Kings
and check Knights still attacked the
move I play is King g8 which is itself
kind of an ugliness but the problem for
whites that really nothing is developed
except for the Queen and the Queen's a
target in a lot of lines
for example if let's say pawn to knight
in this position Bishop take King b1 all
of a sudden I have rook e8 and I'm
winning
because the Queen is skewered to the e1
square so however the Queen moves rook
e1 wings material and she realized that
I shouldn't mention she was taking a ton
of time around then around this point
and she played the move I'm just going
based off memory here I believe she
played Knight to f3
I played Knight to d5 again this was
just all the computer line I just
happened to prepare before the game she
played Bishop to c4 and now very very
important computer move which
essentially equalizes or neutralizes the
the whole pressure that light has in the
position and if I don't play this move
I'll probably be in trouble
the problem for black is because the
King is in the center and has given up
castling rights you have to kind of get
cleaned off the board as quickly as
possible so the key move is Queen e7
moving backwards but forcing a Queen
trade and what happened the game I took
I took should mention the Queen is pin
so there's no Queen take d5 she took and
I believe this was a final move of my
preparation I'll actually ask you guys I
want to see your opinion should black
take that the bishop or the King
this should be pure intuition
exciting you're going to take the queen
with the king
yeah you take the king because you want
your team to go to d6 and such kind of a
weird computer line like a lot of
bizarre moves where your lead pieces
hanging you take that the king rather
than the bishop but from this position I
managed to two out player later in the
game I think my bishop forget exactly
what happened I think that this would
came to h6 and rook came to see file and
there were enough imbalances to play for
wait so going back now hopefully dot
like how it gives you a better
understanding of White's potential
problems where if the center opens up
then all I could have some problems with
King safety and that's exactly what
happened in the game I played a few
months ago instead of we go back to this
position my opponent did play a three
plays s3 maybe a little bit
over-ambitious not necessarily attacking
nice and he's actually preparing to meet
Bishop f5 with E for now what I wanted
to do in this position I wanted to play
Bishop a5 allowing you for I was hoping
that something like this would work take
take and then Queen take d4 and then
just sacrifice the bishop and attack the
King the problem I saw with this line is
that White has neither three developing
with tempo and I realize there's
probably just not enough compensation
here so I can't you calculated that line
before going into any of it and I
realized I have kind of a tricky way to
make things work in my favor instead of
playing Bishop f5 immediately I throw in
kind of the simple move h6 and what this
does it provokes him to play the shifts
back to h4 which was actually a very key
mistake what he should have done was
take on s6 but after Bishop h4 now I
play Bishop a5
and that's the main difference between
this line and the previous line without
including h6 is that if you play d4 here
which he did I take
he takes I take this move Knight f3
it's very something that with Queen III
so what I did I drove the bishop away
from g5 so I can have access to be three
square and this is actually a kind of a
complex type of thought process in chess
there's actually a name for this type of
thinking where you start with having an
idea the idea doesn't necessarily work
because there's a problem so you fix a
problem first and then you go through
with the initial idea that's called
reciprocal thinking and this is maybe a
bit more complex example of reciprocal
thinking but there's there's other
examples too and if you if you actually
want exercises on reciprocal thinking
you can check out the book imagination
in chess and the book actually allowed
me to sharpen up my my thought process
you can take a seat anywhere yeah don't
be shy just make sure you can see let's
go back so we went into this position
queen take d4 and of course he didn't
fight in Knight f3 given that Queen III
is uh that's right so he took on f6 I
take and I should note that I was
completely okay giving away the bishop
in this position because I knew that
given White's lack of development and
given the fact I can castle really
quickly and that the essential files are
open is going to be a more than enough
compensation for black so now the game
gets fun for for me at least he take out
five reads I Castle King is now safe
rook on the open D file he plays nine of
three and the biggest problem for white
is simply the king the King never had
any opportunities to castle especially
after Bishop c5 basically controlling
both the G 1 and D 1 square
so the king is stuck and this is always
like things you want to look for
especially sometimes a late opening
early middle game where if your opponent
King hasn't Castle Jess look for ways to
try and keep the king of the center so
that's basically what happened like tied
Bishop to I play the most natural move
rook heh this is a pretty painful
position for like what look II need to I
mean you want to get the King safe he
tried to play smooth King f1 and now I
actually want to let you guys think
because this next move for black isn't
the most obvious is all my pieces look
pretty much optimized but the next plan
is really important the question is how
does black make progress to basically
finish off the attack against the white
king roof d2 you're thinking like seven
has an unfortunate I take you to oh you
wanted to dig on f5 that's interesting
idea yeah you can't really take on that
five and one of these things for black
you definitely don't want to trade
Queens
yeah g5 certainly came to my mind it's
like trying to add another resource what
do you say
yeah h3 and then it's kind of hard to
still break through Knight to d5 oh I
see you want to play 93 but
unfortunately night take d5 and yeah you
could take back
um well usually when you're attacking
you don't want to trade off pieces if
it's not gaining you anything usually
the more trades favored the defender
I think I'll go ahead and show you guys
on the fall process I used here is
actually kind of simple and then once
you use this process then hopefully the
idea becomes clear so the first
observation I made is how can I improve
like one of the pieces I looked at my
queen like how can I improve my queen of
course if this was bughouse
or if I could cheat I won't like clean
on f2 so then the next question is how
do I get my queen def to I want it to be
on e3 right how do I get to e3 through E
Sodom and this is a key maneuver queen
e7 now initially it might be hard to
consider and move likely nice timing
because it's the backwards move so this
process where you see the idea before
you see the execution is actually pretty
common where now okay Queenie trees
coming
and unfortunately for slice there's not
too many ways to defend against Queen
tree he plays a very strange night g1
but already at this point swipe saw
light I can pretty much throw in the
towel I mean the night is tied down to
the bishop queen really doesn't have too
many great places to go if he plays
Queen e1 he runs into 92 so he went for
a night g1 with idea that after I play
Queen III he plays my h3 and now I play
the move that you wanted to play it
because the nights on h3 rather than
after heat so I have to move 52 yep oh
so usually you want to look at the whole
picture but in this game I was mainly
focused on the King because that was
White's biggest target that was like the
biggest weakness in the position because
he never got to castle so I was like
constantly looking for like the mating
ideas or ideas to kind of use a king in
some sort of tactic so actually if we
look at some
if we look at this position like I saw
the King is incorporated a lot of
tactics like if my knight ever moves can
maneuver to to d5 or to d5 and then
eventually and this never played out in
the game so I was also always looking at
how the King could be exploited so this
game goes to show that sometimes attack
is a lot more valuable than material I
didn't mention this but my opponent
played very quickly in the opening grab
material early without understanding the
consequences and sometimes that's what
separates kind of the maybe lower levels
from the much higher levels is a ability
to make the judgment when to take
material and when to maybe focus on King
safety in this game King safety first
next game I want to show is in a very
topical opening these days from the
London system anyone know what the
London is or seen the London before
maybe one person even if you don't know
what it is I'm sure maybe you ran into
it at some point it's essentially kind
of a setup for wipes which is extremely
easy to learn and understand but it's
also a very trendy opening at the
Grandmaster level especially these days
a lot of high-level players are applying
it including myself for both sides and
it's an opening for whites where just to
kind of give you an overview like
usually plays d4 Bishop f4 and Knight of
three III see 3-digit e3 castle maybe
some small variations of this but this
is like the main setup and usually when
I teach beginners I like to teach them
the London because it's just so easy if
you memorize where like peaceful pieces
want to go it's very solid and it's hard
to crack so in this game we're going to
see black cracking the London setup and
now black is a very strong grandmaster
Victor la Janica from the Czech Republic
and his rating is I guess when this was
played in 2010 whose rating was just
below
2700 so we're going to see how it's
super close to super GM deals with
London opening d4 d5 HTML 4 5 6 5 3 and
he plays the line that I like to play
phrase this move C 5 and this is
actually one of my kind of favorite
recommendations against the London
because what black is trying to do is
take advantage of white setup as early
as possible and the main idea is to
eventually play Queen b6 and target the
b2 pawn because addition is no longer
odds you want so we'll see this playoffs
III 96 c3 and Queen b6 so this is
actually kind of a pretty well-known
position where after Queen b6 white had
some choice to make how to defend upon
on on b2
now the most common move here and the
move that white played in the game was
Queen b3 some other moves maybe aren't
as effective a move like III is really
weakening because if black let's say
black takes on d4 and then take there's
always all these ideas of potential for
Bishop b4 check I'm actually curious in
this position if black can just play e5
looks really interesting and if white
takes and just go for Bishop b4 92 94
and then it's not a 3 Bishop g4 and
while I have some headaches with all the
pins I'm not sure if that line moves
entirely accurate but it just
demonstrates some month some dangerous
ideas for black so let's look at the
mainline Queen b3 and now a very nice
move for black c4 well black wants is
for white to take on b6 because after
886 yes there's double pawns but this is
actually a nice structure for black
because the open a file a choose kind of
a long-term target and it's actually
interesting if I played some of like a
three here then black has this plan of
b5 and then actually ready to play d4
so if 1092 black and displayed before
taking advantage of the pin and if
politic might take some early activity
for black so if we go back what what
whites in the game and this is the most
common move white just a clean teacher
so so now yeah you know the move Bishop
f5 have you seen this before no yeah so
this was the common idea especially for
the London is because the Queen was tied
down to the beat do pawn you take
advantage of it tactically Bishop a5 and
the bishop can't be taken because then
black wings upon and then ends up
winning the look so this is that five is
a nice moves to play over the board
white pretty much has to play Queen t1 I
should mention Queen d2 is almost never
good because my equal
so queen c1 and now now I really like
the way logic of play because I play
this line before it's black and normally
what I do is maybe play some slow move
like each like e6000 he really
understood kind of the the tackle
moments which are about to come up so he
played nine h5 it's going straight away
trying to get the bishop pair white
plays Bishop g3 and now s6 blacks not in
the rush to take the bishop because
basically Knight take G trade can be
played at any time what large nikka
wants to do is play e5 and just take
over the center when lights king is
stuck in the center and we're actually
going to see the same theme where white
never ended up getting to Castle a third
white never ended up casting this game
because black was just too quick to open
up the center and now there was just too
much pressure
so I played Knight bTW to blacks 85 take
my take g3 with nice intermediate move
take and night tick so a lot of things
got traded off and then we get to this
position and at this point it actually
looks like White's next move it
is somewhat dangerous while 84 and black
does have to be careful here because
black is a little bit overextended and
center especially the see for fun is a
target and if the d5 line goes away then
black center could crumble so I was
really impressed with the way logica
handled this position kind of responded
to White's threats and then eventually
created threats of his own so the move
here for black is actually very calm
Bishop g6 maintaining the tension it
does a lot like to take on d5 but now
black to move this next move is like
very critical if you don't play this
move you could be in trouble if you play
this move then whites and troubled so
black to move find the best move very
good this is c5 simply developing with
tempo and this position really really
favors the two bishops because basically
wide open and especially this diagonal
especially that's two pawn is very hard
to tend the fact that a file is also
wide open and as we'll see white light
really struggle to come back
I take c4 is played take Guinea - oh why
not
efore well Bishop Iggy four simple
answer so yeah there's actually really
no way to defend f2 if you play s3 then
there's Bishop s2 it's just things fall
apart for white so White's best chance
was to try and get counter play but okay
the King wasn't looking so so pretty
after King e2 classics was played and I
taking five and I was just Castle Lux
just had done with development got the
King safe ready to pull the rook on eh
and wide is nowhere close to solving the
countless problems that he has with his
pieces so let's just zoom forward let's
see how the game kind of soft 96
rook e8 intermediate move the King found
itself on c4 now I will say that I
wasn't entirely impressed with how the
game ended because it actually took
maybe 20 or so move for black to
actually convert the position it seemed
like there should have been delay I
think if you turn on the engine here the
engine will fail like +10 and find the
most precise limit of winning but what
black did was good enough rookie for
Queen b6 Bishop e3 clean one rook F to
this all the pieces come into play then
white took so essentially black strips
up a queen for a rook I think the
computer had some maybe quicker way but
that it was just a matter of converting
a winning endgame so things got traded
the D pawn was slightly annoying I'll be
careful here is black please don't take
the D pawn because I'm Bishop c4 check
and you lose so okay
grandmaster doesn't block into that and
be pawns blockaded and then she wins the
the D pawn I should mention if Khan c5
here does anyone know what Lac was going
to play
you said something right please yeah
probably Queenie six and after it take
just here this is probably just good
enough to him you just want to make sure
that you have this counter tackling e6
so I played a five and then the rest of
the game eventually the queen is just
too much this should be fourth time so
if you know you're going to play someone
who plays a London I would recommend
knowing this game maybe not memorize a
whole thing by heart but definitely know
through the opening you should probably
know at least remember this Bishop f5
idea if you go back somewhere earlier
yeah remember this Bishop f5 idea
against Queen t2 and then to go even
further remember 90 h5 followed by F 695
so as a London player myself I'll give
away a secret and I'll tell you what I
do to avoid this line as I was actually
debating beforehand whether to tell you
guys but now that you brought it up
I'll go ahead and tell you how I avoid
the sign as white so when White's played
c3 then he's allowing the game to enter
these like Queen b6 lines and I would
argue Queen b6 is already equalizing
I've studied this pretty extensively on
I don't see how white maintains any sort
of advantage so the move that I like to
play is might be e2 and it tricks a lot
of people because a lot of people aren't
used to this move order and if black
goes for Queen b6 the position is
completely different and white has a
move here pawn takes e5 and I have a lot
of my own opening preparations stemming
from this position and there's lines
after Queen takes e5 which are very
comfortable for whites but then there's
also lines after Queen take b2 which
gets very messy for Queen
B to mainline I have in my crafted rook
be one Queen take a to fish' p5 and
white has gambit adapt on to get more
active play and I think is a London
player it makes sense to go for this
position where there's a lot of
opportunities to play for some advantage
so any further questions don't want me
to reveal any more secrets
but yeah it's a it's important like if
you play an opening really for either
side that you know kind of the nuance is
especially like early in the move order
because the same team applies and other
openings to where if you play a move
maybe before another move it could
affect normal position and you want to
be aware of that especially those things
that you like so how do we move on a
next game to look at let's say with the
theme on the London show you another
game now this game you can actually use
the preparation against my version of
the London I'll show you how so d4 d5
it's going to be pretty much the same
sort of line to c5 now here white played
T 3 this is also a different move or
also maybe gearing up if black plays in
early Queen b6 here blacks 86 now I
should mention before we go any further
this game was played very recently at
the US Women's Championship and maybe if
you guys were following the tournament
you saw this game is between Jennifer
you and on a share image if you guys are
familiar with those players on a share
of itch right now is I think teaching
the ladies night or maybe was teaching
ladies night sorry
um yeah I think she's played local
tournaments too she doesn't live too far
away in this game she unleashed like
really really strong preparation against
London and she started with this movie
six and if we notice this movie six kind
of limits any Bishop f5 ideas later on
but I will say that if we look at the
other line that I just showed with 9f
396 and I showed this might be d to move
I said Queen b6 was met with D takes e5
usually black will play e6 here anyway
and then it will transpose to the game
so there's a lot of trans positions and
if you're first learning this I would
say don't worry too much about the
transpositions but do know that they
exist and you might walk into certain
things that you want to be prepared for
this game
b6 was fight earlier if it still goes
into kind of same position and on this
preparation was really impressive
because normally in the main line is
Bishop to d6 and there's a ton of games
which stem from here but what she played
was an early feat 84 and I should
mention that she's actually just
following a game that Wesley so played
from a few months ago and it's another
kind of piece of general general advice
where if you're looking for maybe
openings to player openings to to learn
then it's a great idea to follow the top
layers in the world they're always kind
of lis unleashing new ideas and Leslie
so used a very similar form of
preparation which this game was
basically modeled after so c64 eat 84
and now an i thi and this is a Leslie
so's idea which now is using and idea is
again kind of take event or try and take
advantage of white setup and
in this case try and get the bishop air
so white didn't want to give up
disrepair or white plays Bishop to g5 a6
lipslide and now Bishop III so actually
both sides are doing some awkward things
black pepper pollen f6 which is kind of
awkward the lights with the bishop on e3
which see what kind of awkward and then
not on a chive of course is kind of
awkward to I should mention white is
threatening to trap tonight would be
flicks the g4 here so now the question
becomes how does flack prepare to meet
g4 what can black do to defend against
the threat yes there should be six going
on so it turns out that white ended up
being more awkward than black or yeah
white end up being more awkward than
black giving black and early advantage
white plays g3 here stopping nine f4 but
it felt a little bit unusual black
castle why played Bishop g2 and now on
to played a really good move and I
believe this move was the move that was
B so played against Geary and it's a
very difficult move to meet so I'll let
you guys think in this position black to
move try and put the most pressure on
white as possible hi very good you just
want to play f4 and open up a file and
try and take advantage of White's whole
setup because the white pieces right now
are not very harmonious last pieces on
the other hand they're working towards
some common goal
so with f5 coming or sorry at for coming
uh white had to do something a little
bit crazy and that's what happened
ninety-five was played it's crazy
because now there's a lot of things
attack that's right as attacks place but
also this one in h5 team so what
transpired was at four was played even
more crazy
now the bishops hanging lights still
hanging nice attack twice so a lot of
chaos going on usually the the strong
players can
actually through this and we try and
find the best continuation from Knight
takes c6 Pontic Queen take take take so
now the dust kind of settles and if we
count material white is actually up upon
white one that pond that was a march
forward on that file but if we evaluate
the position we should notice that black
is significantly better setup than white
if we look at like pieces of King
especially still stuck in the center
can't Castle kingside
bishop doing nothing on g2 not doing
nothing on d2 black having two bishops
and actually these are two very good
dishes so bishop on e6 is already good
the bishop on c8 could potentially be
good if it goes
to a6 eventually so I would argue black
has more than enough condensation for
the pawn here and that was certainly
demonstrated in the game and on just
started with with initiative she in very
simple threat rook b8 and here
Jennifer you played a very questionable
move which just kind of look like
self-destruction I think what white
shadows on is rook e1 but Jennifer
Castle queenside not recommended like
castling into your opponent's attack
because now after cleaning five White's
King is under major fire and like a lot
of light pieces are on the Kings side
being no help at all so King b1 inside
now let me ask you guys did anyone was
anyone like following the championship
yeah so Queen takes e3 is a candidate
move but we'll want to discuss further
now I'm asking if anyone followed the
championship because this was actually a
kind of new Tory scheme especially for
the round
this game was a longest game of the
round it should have been over in just a
few moves but it ended up taking like
over 50 or 60 moves black still won but
black made a terrible mistake here
and the terrible mistake is actually
taking Sikri she played this move like
without even thinking and this is what I
was hoping for because this actually
gives white initiative to come back in
the game and I'll just show you what
white did and then we'll come back and
look at game ending move why play Knight
beat three black ones the e3 pawn white
plays rook e1 so black just one two
pawns but white was already up upon so
now black is up upon but White has
initiative and then the position got
like very messy and it was kind of a
rollercoaster game but White's uh
succeeded in kind of fending off the
attack and getting pieces to reasonable
squares so let's come back to this
position because look honest should have
done was recognized that Queen takes c3
isn't the only candidate move and that's
really important in chess if you see a
good move don't play it immediately look
at your other options there might be
better moves so black to move in this
position what's the other key move yeah
so you have Queen a3 or Bishop a3 any
other like options to consider
rook take b2 or you said rook F 2 right
okay yeah you said work actually I was
hearing worked a feature
so maybe refusing it um yeah there's a
lot of interesting options here and this
is a position where yeah black should
just be much better but you want to take
your time to make sure that you're
playing the best option to move to
calculate first is rook take me to it's
almost forcing because King has to take
back and then if there's a line that
like leads to a win then you don't have
to really look at anything else and that
was a case where Brooke take me to
actually just wings on the spot does
take a little bit of calculation but
we'll see maybe it wasn't too difficult
so it will take you to sacking the rook
and this was very common like when
you're when you have a lot of pieces
aimed at your home is king what for
sacrifices look for ways to
just tear apart the opponent's defense
so light would have to take and then
Queen III King b1 and now now key move
you right now only in really the queen
with attacking you have to bring more
pieces into the tack submission basics
and what this does is basically makes
two threats Bishop to d3 also work to be
so like to try next to b3 and now
actually 93 is clever because it kind of
prevents Bishop d3 and doesn't make
repeat as powerful but now the rook can
infiltrate through a stew and this is
probably what Anna would have had to
activate if she wanted to go through
with the sacrifice and the position is
just completely waiting for black the
best or like the only hope for white is
to try and get kind of play Queenie a
with after Bishop f8 white very quickly
runs out of checks Queen diggy 6 King h8
and white could probably just resign
here I don't see any way to survive
Queen B 2 is coming only attempt is rook
to d2 but now it's just a matter of
finishing off lights after take take
Bishop d3 King any one Queen takes c3
mate so if we look at the notation um
the actual game oh I line was 91 moves
the game could have ended like 525 so
this this game is not a game you should
know by heart because you don't want to
memorize like Maggie one moves but you
want to at least know through nice to
know through Brooke baby to like the
whole sequence of play like all the
opening preparation leading up to this
most amazing like Brook sacrifice and
she didn't play it
luckily for her she won the game but
could have been a lot more beautiful so
okay well any questions so far
we'll move on
um I think we have time for one more
game one of my favorite games of all
time and it was actually played by a
good friend of mine very awesome anyone
heard of very rotten before chess child
chess prodigy there's actually a book
written by Ray roxxon's dad called chess
child and he talks about this specific
game in the book and the game is really
really cool because it features some
like opening novelty but then it
features some positional peace sacrifice
where like even the computer doesn't
understand that black was winning like
the whole game even though the computer
side of light was better for most of the
time so it's best if I just we just go
through it and this game ray was black
and if I remember correctly I'm not
entirely sure about this but there may
have been some norm norm opportunities
on the line for this game where like if
he wins he either gets like a
high-energy and run but I guess you
would have to read the book to to find
out so the game is an opening that I
found to be very annoying over the years
white played what's called the Catalan
after g3 and this was actually a very
trendy opening among grandmasters a lot
of top fighters are playing at these
days at the US Championships we saw
Wesley so play it with some success I
would say pretty much every like top GM
has tightness at some point as whites
and there's actually a pretty well known
series of books by Boris avrech who's
like a leading specialist on this line
and that's one of the most like
recommended book series that he can get
for an opening repertoire but in this
game Ray raphson fade a very kind of
novel idea which before before 2009 when
this game was played it really hadn't
been seen before so he took she's one of
the main lines Bishop e2 then he plays
Bishop before checks is still in kind of
known territory Bishop d2
and now his next move is actually like a
very very move especially for the time
the suicide and his next move I've
actually coined the gray rocks and
variation I think this deserves to be
named after him the move is c5 it's not
only did he win this game which is like
beautiful game he won multiple other
games with the same same exact line and
the idea is to I guess first of all
support the Bishop on b4 and there's a
lot of lines where it gets into like a
really weird pawn structure which may be
difficult to understand at first but
then there's all this kind of long
opening preparation so the game
continues but should take before so you
take before and we should mention that
white is down upon and black how these
two kind of scary-looking pawns on C
form before but why it is eventually
winning one of these pawns back and now
website is a main move here and I see
five I will go off on a small tangent
there is another move here which looks
pretty good Queen a4 I'll just share
just a quick kind of opening secret with
you guys if Queen a for black complain
ninety six which actually allows the
very scary-looking 95 attacking the
pinned piece three times also attacking
c4 but then black has a very calm it
should be seven and if white takes on c6
let's say take take take take there's a
funny idea after Queen takes c6
ninety-seven the white queen can't take
on c4 because black to move and room
material yeah Rick c8 this is just one
of my like nuggets of opening
preparation where on if I ever kind of
gets careless then you're curing the
Queen to the C 1 square so let's look at
the the game 24 it wasn't played 95 was
played going after the the c-4 5 and the
c4 pawn is kind of hard to defend
so rageous gives it up and
seeds with development Castle Knight
takes e4 96 attacking d4y plays e3 and
now very very important move from black
because if we look at it's kind of hard
to figure out how black should complete
development big problem is suspicious on
z8 you would like to play d6 in Bishop
e7 but you can't really do that because
there's a bishop on g2 so what ray did
is very kind of aggressive enterprising
move play e5 it's actually a temporary
pawn sacrifice it's like chooses to take
it and after this position I actually
for myself I have a lot of open
preparation spending in different
variations there's a lot of options here
for whites well I can take with the pawn
with at night could take on p6 first and
then take on e5 y can play d5 in this
game we're just going to focus on d5 um
this is one of the most challenging
moves and after this black really only
has one good move and it's not to move
the knight on c6 the only good move for
black is to play b5 counter attack so
white takes kick take pick so some very
bizarre pawn structure there's kind of a
passed pawn on d6 which is hard to
remove because the bishop supports it
but then black has kind of this
three-on-two majority with his pawns
being ahead of the white pawn on d6 so
very strange position and I think today
there's a there's been a handful of
games from this position and the the
opening theory keeps developing I will
say that I've actually reached this
position as black and I've have it to be
very enjoyable to play I think there's a
lot of dynamic ideas for both sides and
it's the type of position or type of
opening where could play for a win if
you wanted to explode imbalances so
we're going to see what happened the
game white played a three and now okay
ray played Bishop to g4 king c1 and now
Ray's did something which probably was a
mistake at the time he played b3 now
this turned out to actually be a really
good movement later because you'll see
his column b3 was incredibly strong what
he probably should have done and I think
he actually had a another game later on
which reached his position and he played
the other move a5 just to reinforce upon
the point is now you just try and
restrict the Knights and you prevent the
knight from developing to c3 let's look
at what happened the game B 393 rook a
CH and we're going to keep going until
first interesting moment happens a lot
of tension in the center of n cheese
black had to give up the e4 pawn so icon
you three take take
and now c7 and then this point was
really interesting if my first
impression would be that black has to
play look stay here and try and like the
time against the power of the pawn on c7
what ray did was he understood that
white has some deficiencies in his
position and he played a piece sacrifice
which starts with the next lift we
played rook to d4 and it sacrifices the
piece because it allows the ship to b7
and white ends up winning the piece
plays h6 at 5:57 Queen take take so
White's left full piece for on and this
is a position the computer just has no
understanding of if you turn on the
engine here it'll say around +1 for
whites the problem is that this rook is
just stuck and so is the nice and
because both of these pieces are stuck
black has basically infinite time to to
maneuver and to eventually execute the
time that he wants to do so
the just counting the material or just a
direct material situation here is not
entirely relevant to who's better and
it's actually going to be black thing
for the win
and the finale of the game was actually
really enjoyable to watch because all
black had to do was walk the King all
the way up the board eventually you get
you gets there I don't know if this was
the exact path but we'll see where the
King will walk up all the way and then
help out with with some mating ideas so
let's zoom forward King walks up
notice that White's really had no escape
especially this rook on the Queen side
is so so sad
95 57 like tried to create some
complications with the King side pawns
but got nowhere you got to e16 is played
take take and now roughly 2 and now
we're about to see kind of the final
mating idea which I don't know if ray
actually saw from the previous position
but I'm sure he was looking at different
ideas of of how they look the knight
then the King could play a role in
mating the white king so I'll let you
guys try and find the final idea lack to
move and I think those positions just
forced me sorry a rip d1 but then Bishop
takes you want or not KQ d one's
off-limits for now ok by process of
guessing I guess you got the right
person move rooks you to driving the
white king to be one where it's even
more set now how to make further
progress
not f1 very good because you just want
to go to youtube and yeah 92 is very
hard to stop
well nicely to the idea so the only
defensive option for light to stop 92 is
to play 94 but this locks into still 92
disaster nice 82 King Day Guiteau
White's like completely stuck on the
Queen side white White's wishing this
bishop was just off the board so it
would be still me or no it wouldn't be
stalemate nevermind I don't know what
waits wishing for probably not not to
get in the situation but rook see one
from stoppable
so yeah this is one my favorite games
are very rapidly
2009 he just turned 21 so Rey was I can
do math around 13 I don't know if you
want to trust my math but people on
YouTube to look it up so so yeah
hopefully these games were inspirational
especially being lacking in c4 maybe now
you're more equipped to smoking so good
luck in your your own games with d4
thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]